معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد في ظل الخلافات بخصوص هذه
الصفقه هل اراح قرار تاجيل انعقاد الكنيست
حتى وصول رد حماس هل اراح جميع
الفرقاء تاجيل اجتماع الطاقم الوزاري
الامني السياسي الاسرائيلي المصغر هو عكس
حاله الارباك والتخبط الموجوده داخل دائره
صنع القرار في اسرائيل وان كان التاجيل قد
تم تبريره على اساس منع تسريب المعلومات
التي ترد في هذا الاجتماع ومحاوله عدم
اعطاء حركه حماس فرصه للاستفاده منها لذلك
هي تعكس حاله الخلاف المتعمق داخل صناع
القرار في اسرائيل المنقسمين بين من يدعو
الى مواصله الحرب بكل ضراوه وبين من يقول
بانه لا مفر من القبول باطار العام
للاتفاق الذي انتهت اليه مباحثات باريس
والدخول في مفاوضات مباشره من اجل ابرام
صفقه تبادل اسرى على اساس المراحل التي نص
عليها الاتفاق العام ومن ثم تستطيع
اسرائيل اذا ارادت ان تواصل الحرب لكن هم
يدركون جيدا ان موقف حماس الصلب بخصوص ان
تنتهي هذه العمليه الى وقف تام لاطلاق
النار وانسحاب اسرائيلي من قطاع غزه سيشكل
ذلك بمثابه هزيمه في لاسرائيل بنظر ايضا
مواطنيها لكن هذا كله ياتي انعكاسا للخلاف
الجاري في الشارع الاسرائيلي خاصه بعد
المظاهرات التي تتواصل منذ بدايه الحرب من
اجل اعاده كافه الاسرائيليين الاسرى
والمحتجزين والتي وصلت الليله الماضيه الى
ذروه عندما امتدت من حيفا الى قيساريا الى
تل ابيب الى القدس الغربيه الى بئر السبع
وزاد على الشعارات المطالبه بضروره ابرام
صفقه تبادل زادت شعارات تقول تطالب بعزل
نتنياهو وباجراء انتخابات مبكره في
اسرائيل لاختيار قياده جديده هذه الامور
مجتمعه تعكس حاله من الارباك وحاله من
التخبط داخل دائره صنع القرار لدرجه ان
نتنياهو او مؤيدي استمرار الحرب حاولوا ان
يقوموا بمظاهره مضاده ومناهض امس في تل
ابيب لكنهم فشلوا بسبب قله العدد اضطروا
الى فضد مظاهرتهم والانسحاب المظاهرات
المتواصله في اسرائيل تزيد من الشعور لدى
الاسرائيليين بانعدام الثقه تجاه القياده
السياسيه على وجه الخصوص والاستطلاعات
تشير الى انه اذا كان هناك ثمانيه 80%
واكثر من الاسرائيليين يثقون بالقياده
العسكريه فان الذين يثقون بالقياده
السياسيه لا يتجاوز نسبتهم
14%
هذه مجتمعه تدل على الحاله التي تعيشها
اسرائيل في ظل في ظل هذه الظروف والتي
تدفعها للذهاب الى اعتبار ان
عدم ارسال حماس ردها حتى الان يهدف ايضا
الى تعميق الخلاف داخل اسرائيل في ظل
استمرار حاله الحرب في قطاع غزه